[Musik]
willkommen zu einem schnellen
nachrichtenüberblick in der
halbzeitpause die debatte um die
regenbogen beleuchtung des münchner
fußball stadions zeigt wirkung die eben
kommission nennt das umstrittene
ungarische gesetz zu sexuellen
minderheiten eine schande und will
dagegen vorgehen
viele zeigen flagge anne gellinek die
elbphilharmonie leuchtet im regenbogen
outfit das fußballstadion im belgischen
gent das rathaus von münchen eine
regenbogenfarben eine welle der
entrüstung über das ungarische
homosexuellen gesetz rollt durch europa
und wird morgen sogar den gipfel der eu
staats und regierungschefs erfassen
der öffentliche druck zwingt auch die eu
kommissionspräsident hin zum handeln
das ungarische gesetz ist eine schande
dieses gesetz diskriminiert menschen
eindeutig ihrer sexuellen orientierung
wegen nimmt ungarn das gesetz nicht
zurück droht die eu-kommission mit einer
klage vor dem europäischen gerichtshof
ein weiteres von über 100
vertragsverletzungsverfahren die viktor
orban bereits am hals hat der ungarische
premierminister schlägt am nachmittag
zurück nicht sein gesetz dass kinder
schütze sei eine schande sondern die
erklärung der eu kommissionspräsident in
die ungarischen fußball stadien sollen
am abend demonstrativ in den
nationalfarben erstrahlen
die bundeskanzlerin hat so weiterer
vorsicht in der korona krise aufgerufen
wir bewegen uns immer noch auf dünnem
eis sagte merkel im bundestag
unterdessen breitet sich auch in
deutschland die ansteckende delta
variante weiter aus 15 beträgt ihr
anteil an allen neuinfektionen
das ist fast doppelt so viel wie in der
woche davor die inzidenz sinkt dagegen
weiter auf jetzt 7 2 einige corona
testzentren sollen bei den abrechnungen
betrogen haben
deshalb hat die regierung jetzt
schärfere kontrollen beschlossen und pro
schnelltest werden künftig höchstens 11
eur 50 gezahlt bisher waren es 18 euro
die bundesregierung hat den haushalt für
das nächste jahr auf den weg gebracht
keine hilfen mehr klimaschutz und
fehlende einnahmen führen zu einer
höheren neuverschuldung
sie klettert auf fast 100 milliarden
euro
eine vorläufige zahl endgültig wird erst
nach der bundestagswahl über den
haushalt 22 entschieden
offiziell gilt einen waffenstillstand
doch das bürgerkriegsland libyen bleibt
ein pulverfass eine konferenz in berlin
heute sollte die lage stabilisieren und
wahlen vorbereiten
dazu hatte außenminister maß unter
anderem vertreter der libyschen
übergangsregierung die usa sowie
russland und die türkei eingeladen
ankara und moskau haben kämpfer in
libyen beide länder verpflichteten sich
nun diese abzuziehen noch die
lottozahlen sie lauten 5 69 20 33 46 und
die superzahl 5 weitere gewinnzahlen auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
das wetter bleibt in teilen heftig im
norden meist freundlich sonst schauer
und gewitter teils unwetter mit
starkregen 18 bis 27 grad
so viel von uns ihnen jetzt viel spaß
beim fußball und bis morgen